my dear brothers and sisters I just want
to give a warning to my brothers and
sisters Islam about some Iraqis or
quotes of quotes
some of them in reality are magicians
they are Sahara may Allah curse them and
so how do you know them if if Iraqi asks
you for your mother's name is this man
is a magician also my sisters best thing
I mean for brothers and sisters
if it's extreme necessity look for
trustworthy rugby for sisters make sure
you have your brother or there's another
sister with you as well mention if you
have no
um
also be aware of Iraq is sent to your
sister send me your picture let me see
if I have any bruises in your body if
this decision this all this is this guy
is a shaytan stay away from this type of
people so my advice to you my brothers
and sisters in Islam in our time there's
a lot of share thing out there who are
trying to utilize this rockya thing to
many look at the people to abuse people
so try to learn yourself
and be patient love you come and stay
away from this out there some brothers
who are doing it for the sake of Allah
helping people however the answer is